26 décembre
1991 l empire du mal ni plus la nouvelle
russie libérer des chaînes de
l'idéologie communiste se dirige
finalement vers un avenir radieux le
monde libre lui tend les bras fin de
l'oppression pour les peuples concernés
écrasé jusque là par le totalitarisme
mais au delà d'un tremblement de terre
géopolitique qu'est ce que c'est a
signifié pour les gens ordinaires si
vous ou moi je vous félicite
c'est en raison de la situation qui
s'écrit avec les créations de la
communauté des états indépendants
je mets fin à mes fonctions de président
de l'urss
n'a presque plus idiot que social ce
furent des jours noirs pour l'union et
pour la russie ce furent des jours noirs
pour moi aussi même si je n'ai pas perdu
mon sang-froid
j'ai signé un décret pour démissionner
de la présidence de l'urss je crois que
je n'avais pas le droit d'agir autrement
si helsinki a succédé à gorbatchev à la
tête de la nouvelle russie a lui même
reconnu qu'il avait tort de penser que
tout allait s'arranger need lettich ce
qui oriente
ses murs la politique ce serait un tel
bouleversement politique un tel
changement politique dont le pays ne
s'est passé pacifiquement dans aucun
autre étape personne parmi nous n'avait
fait l'expérience d'un état démocratique
avec la liberté d'expression et la
liberté du marché a dit mme craxi chez
scavo gosses audace ça sent bon oeil ce
dont brice n'est communiqué avoir au
niveau taco de matraque qui chasserait
paco et folie
inspiré par cette vague d'euphorie
démocratique j'avais l'impression ainsi
que les économistes impliqué que nous
allions traverser rapidement la période
qui aboutirait à des résultats positifs
à cette transformation
ce changement du système politique qu'il
y aurait une certaine amélioration de la
vie des gens et nous l'avons dit à voix
haute c'était une erreur
monseigneur juge didier
drogba
et les conséquences étaient graves les
gens ont perdu leurs économies
les revenus ont été divisés par 2 5
jusqu'à 80% de la population s'est
retrouvée sous le seuil de pauvreté les
chercheurs aller travailler sur les
marchés les ingénieurs dans les cafés
les médecins les professeurs étaient
parmi les plus pauvres touchant des
salaires de misère souvent versés en
retard pour des postes qui nécessite
pourtant plusieurs années d'études les
coupons pour acheter du sucre du lait du
pain sont entrés dans la vie des russes
pour longtemps dans le pays des signes
de guerre civile apparaissait et enfin
une guerre civile de grande ampleur a
éclaté évidemment j'ai vu tout cela
surtout quand je suis devenu directeur
du service fédéral de sécurité à cette
même époque
notre système de protection sociale
avait été complètement détruit certains
secteurs économiques stoppé net le
système de santé était en ruines l'armée
s'est retrouvé dans un état lamentable
des millions et des millions de gens se
sont retrouvés à vivre sous le seuil de
pauvreté il ne faut pas l'oublier ça
surtout mal tourné au sein des ex
républiques soviétiques des conflits
ethniques ont éclaté presque partout une
guerre entre la géorgie et l'abkhazie
entre la géorgie et l'institut du sud
conflit au nagorny karabach guerre
civile au tadjikistan et beaucoup
d'autres encore à tunis quant aux photos
que vous suiviez des effusions de sang
en russie
les affrontements interethniques faisait
rage des conflits causés par des
facteurs raciaux nationaux et le
mollet peut-on oublier que c'est sous
gorbatchev bien demi million d'arméniens
ont été expulsés d'azerbaïjan et que des
dizaines de milliers ont été sauvagement
assassinés
des gens ont été brûlés dans leur
voiture je le sais n'était ce pas ce
gorbatchev que les soulèvement anti
russe au kazakhstan et un massacre dans
la vallée de ferghana ont eu lieu
on ne sait pas comment mettre fin au
conflit sanglant entre peuples il été
autrement que par la loi et la force
prime une zone
si nous avions mis un terme ne serait ce
qu'une seule fois cette querelle
interethniques
qui sont toujours provoqué par des
politiciens qui tentent de se servir de
ces conflits pour prendre le pouvoir
rien de tout cela ne serait arrivé chez
nous
le 17 mars 1991 un référendum a été
organisé une seule question sur le
bulletin de vote pensez vous qu'elle est
nécessaire de maintenir l'union des
républiques socialistes soviétiques
en tant que fédération renouveler deux
républiques souveraines égal dans
laquelle les droits et libertés de
l'homme de toutes nationalités seront
pleinement garantis samson 16,4 pour
cent des votants ont répondu oui mais
les dirigeants de l'union en ont décidé
autrement je pense que la chute de
l'urss si vous voulez les accords de
biovail vierge
les indépendances tout ça était perçu
par la majorité des gens à l'époque
comme une espèce de tout
catastrophique et quand poutine a dit
que c'était une catastrophe je pense
qu'il a bien reflété le sentiment est
issu de la majorité des personnes y
compris pour des gens qui passent
initialement
qui était même favorable à la
pérestroïka ou qui étaient tout à fait
favorables à la démocratisation à la
liberté d'expression qu'ils étaient
contents de sortir de la période
autoritaire totalitaire soviétique
ça a été perçu comme une catastrophe
parce que c'était une catastrophe dans
la vie quotidienne pour les repères
étaient perdus ce sont des années où
j'ai vu vraiment des gens pris de
panique donc comment on va faire en fait
sortir simplement et donc la perception
des événements politiques je suis dans
la majorité de la population l'époque
elle l est les événements politiques ne
sont pas perçus comme des événements
politiques sur lesquels on sait résoudre
est comme ça à froid on aurait des idées
mais ils sont perçus exactement dans un
continuum avec les événements de la vie
quotidienne socio économique la perte de
revenus la baisse du niveau de revenus
considérables et puis le fait dans ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui 30 ans après l'effondrement
de l'urss le conflit russie occident n'a
pas disparu pour mikhaël gorbatchev à
cause du chaos et des dégâts sur
l'économie soviétique et il était
impossible de créer une relation
équitable avec l'occident
comment peut-on espérer des relations
d'équité avec les états unis avec
l'occident dans cette situation c'est la
première chose deuxièmement est tout
aussi important c'est le sentiment de
triomphe en occident notamment aux états
unis
la tête l'arrogance l'autosatisfaction
ils se sont proclamés vainqueurs de la
guerre froide alors qu'on avait ensemble
sauver le monde de la confrontation non
les vainqueurs ont décidé de construire
un nouvel empire d'où l'idée de
l'expansion de l'otan
même à l'époque nous avions les
informations selon lesquelles certaines
personnes y compris parmi les dirigeants
du pays se réjouissait de nos
difficultés et après l'effondrement de
l'union ils n'ont pas caché leur joie
derrière les grandes décisions des
hommes politiques il ya toujours les
gens ordinaires qui subissent les
conséquences
ceux qui ont décidé la chute de l'urss
applaudi par l'occident ont aussi sommé
la misère et la mort pour des milliers
de russes et 30 ans près on arrive
toujours pas surmonté les tragédies de
cette époque